it is July 28 2023 and you're watching
the code report you might want to be
sitting down because I've got some big
news for you aliens are real according
to government whistleblowers do we have
the bodies of the pilots who piloted
this craft biologics came with some of
these recoveries yeah were they I guess
human or non-human biologics
what's even weirder though is that they
recovered this strange code from their
spacecraft it was so disturbing in fact
that they posted it to stack Overflow
but it was immediately closed as
duplicate because it looks so similar to
another language that I won't name if
you're an elderly programmer born before
2022 you might remember a website called
stack overflow when it launched in 2008
it revolutionized the programming World
by allowing the average person to build
complex software by simply Googling and
copying and pasting code from this
website it accelerated Atwood's law
stating that any application that can be
written in JavaScript will eventually be
written in JavaScript which is actually
a law formed by Jeff Atwood one of Stack
overflow's co-founders that's been
proven True by science time and time
again as programmers we all owe a huge
debt of gratitude to all the stack
Overflow contributors without their
selfless contributions it'd be nearly
impossible for us to build our failed
side projects stack Overflow has been a
huge success for one simple reason
people will do anything for fake
Internet points having high stack
Overflow rep is like the ultimate clout
for a programmer you walk into a c-sharp
conference with a hundred thousand stack
Overflow rep you'll be mobbed by clout
Chasers who would literally do
just to get into your LinkedIn Network
and when you surpass a million rep
people will start to name their kids
after you like little baby skeet here
but the Golden Age of stack Overflow has
come to an end and over the last six
months traffic to the site has tanked
before I explain why and what they're
doing about it though I want to show you
an awesome open source product from our
sponsor graph base the hardest thing
about building a full stack application
is not the front end or the back end
it's getting the two of them to talk to
each other graph base can take multiple
data sources and Stitch them together
into a unified graphql API allowing you
to access your data from any front end
with type safety and intellisense what I
especially like is that it uses
typescript for configuration instead of
error-prone yaml and provides graphql
directives to make it easy to build out
your schema and its open API connector
can easily integrate any restful API
under the hood it's built with rust and
can be run locally with a single command
and is one of the only solutions out
there that can be deployed to the edge
allowing you to easily cache data and
run resolvers globally if you're
building a serious application you'll
definitely want to have graph base on
your radar now back to stack Overflow
traffic and overall engagement has
declined nearly 50 50 percent over the
last year Based on data from the website
itself that was leaked by someone with
over 25 000 rep but what's behind the
shocking decline well I think we all
know the reason in Japan they call it
orokonah haribato also known as
artificial intelligence Chachi BT
basically took all of Stack overflows
content and reflects it back to you in
ways that are custom tailored for your
use case it's pretty clear that the copy
and paste engineer is being replaced by
the proofed engineer if I were to guess
I'd say my stack Overflow usage has
declined about 60 to 70 percent with the
rise of AI tooling over the last year
for many though this is Poetic Justice
stack Overflow is littered with bodies
of wannabe programmers who quit learning
to code after their first well thought
out question was downvoted insulted and
closed by the high value Alpha coders
well as of yesterday stack Overflow
announced overflow AI a new generative
AI tool that can create answers based on
the stack Overflow data set but it begs
the question if I'm someone who answers
programming questions all day why would
I continue doing that when AI is using
my content and stealing all my cloud on
top of that all the other big llms like
gpt4 already drank the stack Overflow
milkshake and used all that data when
training their models to understand the
situation more clearly we can look to
Mother Nature in the desert when a snake
becomes extremely hungry and stressed it
may begin to consume itself in
desperation but obviously this can't go
on forever and it's not just stack
Overflow AI is the final frontier for
Humanity and coincidentally you can't
spell alien without AI funny how they
both appear at the same time after
millions of years this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one